I think for people who played war for
cybertron what you're going to see is
that we listened we actually listen to
what the press with the fans and you
know that crazy little internal voice
inside our heads was telling us that
this game really needed and that was
variety that was you know every
character really allowing the player to
get in their hand understand their story
because they're all different than all
different perspectives about what's
happening but also from a gameplay point
of view push you challenging you embrace
transformation while each character
still feels unique was cut paramount to
what this games all about transformers
is really all about choice you know the
difference tuna on a button Decepticon a
good kind of a guy for not big
transformer sman it's choice there's no
technology DIF you just chosen one side
of the other and so we embrace that in
transformation we let you choose when
you want to transform and play that way
that you want to play each each level is
really geared around a specific
character and and that it was was a
really interesting choice for us early
on it was it was kind of one of the
biggest choices that we made what that
allowed us to do is deliver a much
deeper story because now you can kind of
associate with this one character and
see where their heads at it also allowed
us to build the level design around what
that character could and couldn't do so
I think it it really enabled us to kind
of free ourselves from all right letting
them you know having to deal with all
these potential characters and said how
do we deliver the best jazz experience
we could possibly do multiplayer online
play is you know its core to what we did
on war for Cybertron and you know we're
being a little tight-lipped on on all
the features for that yet but I can tell
you it's coming back you know and tell
you that was very well received and the
people really liked it but the one thing
that Frank they don't think we delivered
or well enough on was creating your own
transformer we really just prank off the
side of what that could be and so when
we looked at multiplayer / said are the
one thing that we have to go to 11 on
it's great you're on transformer and we
did it
you